is this racist do chinese people have
guess who
god damn handsome ass indian look at you
are you indian or pakistani indian yeah
relax there's [ __ ]
two billion of you you don't have to get
that
hindu muslim sick what are you
no [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying what's
the background why y'all take so long
for this [ __ ]
from bombay and what you're just naming
more [ __ ] that you know doesn't
what's their religious background
they're not religious either
what about their parents
you don't know them you know
you know i know you're lying right you
know
you know i know you're lying right now
none of us ever met a non-religious
indian parent in our life
none of us ever met anomaly indian
parent indian parent non-religious
uh-uh that's what he got to say because
his girl ain't indian that's why
i'm a big fan of asians i think they're
the best group i think they're number
one
i don't think they get the credit they
deserve i'm an asian supremacist all the
way
i think they're better than the rest any
asian people here
hey all right you should be working come
on
what are you doing having a good time
that's not the asian i know god damn
it i want you dealing blackjack or
sitting on a box peeling something come
on
big fan best group easily the best group
no love you guys get the short on the
chopstick it's pretty unfair
so quiet so secure asians every other
group's got to brag and boast
every group's got a slogan black people
i'm black and i'm proud white people
white power hispanics
not an asian ninja's head down grades up
that's it
angel the bet you never hear about asian
crime never if i was an asian guy i
would just start mugging people like hey
it's my word against yours are you
chinese
yes what's uh where is your family from
taiwan
taiwan so you you were made in taiwan
do you speak mandarin yeah and and your
girl
she's not a girl
wow that's [ __ ] up you could at least
pretended you know to make him feel like
a man
you didn't have to [ __ ] emasculate
him in front of everybody
and your girl i'm not his [ __ ] girl
please you wish
what's your back you're asian right miss
what type of asian
your taiwanese that's a good one
nah that's a good one that's like china
2.0
right because taiwanese
right i'm getting that right taiwanese
were like [ __ ] we out
and then they were like japan's too far
let's just stop right here this island
now this island's good we're not going
all the way
you're like those indians that made it
to like trinidad
you know the indians are like we're
going to america and then the first
island they're like [ __ ] pull over
this is far enough i'm ready
you know who don't have no beef with
anybody's asian people i see how y'all
be doing
[Applause]
yeah i just lay in the cut i don't think
all people asian people beef with
is other asian people like if you call
a korean guy chinese i've done this
they'll flip out
hey what make you think of chinese
i am korean i look
chinese yes [ __ ] dude look
chinese that's why i said it
it's an accident look at the untrained
eye you all look chinese to me
it's a mistake i'm not trying to offend
you some people say all black people
look alike
we don't get bent out of shape we
normally just call those people
police okay asian needs advice from bill
burr
bill i love your podcast you're really
awesome um
asian mail uh chinese with squinty
[ __ ] eyes and can't drive for [ __ ]
dude you don't got a [ __ ] on yourself
um anyways i need your advice i came to
america
i guess i always do i'm a bald pasty
[ __ ] um anyways i need your advice i
came to america
a year ago and i really love tall slim
irish german girls with red hair
jesus christ i just missed i just missed
being your [ __ ] dreamboat
i think they're beautiful well i'm not
tall am i uh blonde is
beautiful too never seen such beauty
where i'm from
holy moly the problem is i'm not like
tall and confident like white guys
and i live in texas jesus christ dude
this is a [ __ ] reality show waiting
to happen
i tried to ask this redhead at the gym
out and she won't take me seriously
all right time the [ __ ] out dude
hat off to you for the [ __ ] balls you
got
you came here from china you've learned
the [ __ ] language
right you're in texas you're at the gym
you're talking [ __ ]
right gives a [ __ ] you went up to the
plate you didn't get on base who gives a
[ __ ]
talk to another redhead talk to a blunt
talk to whatever the [ __ ] you want to
keep talking to him
he said what do i need to do to date a
redhead
no jesus christ wait because i'm a
redhead like i know like there's some
secret [ __ ] handshake
he said they want me to be their asian
friend but i really want to marry him
bang them and have cute kids
this is driving me nuts i mean am i
going against nature
is an asian guy dating white girls
frowned upon and not accepted in america
thanks in advance i don't really cuss
that much and don't mean to offend you
but uh wanted to talk and act like you
jimmy chow out um
yeah okay is is asian guys dating white
guys found upon like everything is
frowned upon in every [ __ ] country
generally speaking people are afraid of
anything [ __ ] new
who gives a [ __ ] literally like that guy
before me who said he wanted to play
piano
if he told somebody he wanted to do that
you know
um i think initially people be
encouraging or whatever
they're always p there's always going to
be people telling you not to do [ __ ]
is this what you want to do sir yes then
i would go out and do it all right
so it sounds like to me from your email
that you've uh
you know i don't know it's like you just
got into the majors
okay it's the first week you haven't
gotten your first hit yet
what are you gonna do you're just gonna
quit baseball go back down to the miners
[ __ ] that keep i would keep talking
every time you hit on a woman you get
better at it
all right and i would just uh i would
just continue like
you're doing everything you need to do
you're going to the gym you're staying
in shape
and you're talking [ __ ] i mean i don't i
don't i don't see anything wrong with
your game plan
other than you know it hasn't happened
for you yet and
um this is something uh
you know it's gonna take a minute you
know if you just walk up and talk to
some chick at the gym and get laid i
mean then
everybody would be [ __ ] doing it the
reason why most people don't do it
is because they know that 99.9 of the
time you're gonna get the [ __ ]
heisman
hey easy easy this is my elliptical over
here this is your elliptical over there
right [ __ ] off right and for all the
women they're going like
can you just like not hit on us at the
gym can you just [ __ ] nod can i just
have this [ __ ] place
hey they make gyms for that they make
the old ladies [ __ ] gyms
all right the [ __ ] you're gonna go there
working out looking good and then you're
upset that a guy's coming up and hitting
on you
someday ladies some days they're not
gonna want to talk to you
take it from somebody okay who the women
they don't even
they don't even like you don't even like
register like i'm like i'm a [ __ ] i'm a
sir
i became a sir or a mister like [ __ ]
15 years ago
and it's over all right okay
you know what i don't want to see asian
dealers that's who i don't want to see
with the personalities of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when i do gamble i want a [ __ ] dealer
with a person
i like the store i like that [ __ ] who
are you going to hire
if you have things that there's only two
people in the world
that that care about their job more than
their own life and that's
asians and [ __ ] hindus
who'll die if you own a cigarette store
a hindu will [ __ ] die
protecting your cigarettes yeah you're
so right
so [ __ ] what what i'll walk with you you
know how rob your story be if i work out
two gangsters with [ __ ] guns and a
hindu will [ __ ]
jump over the counter half of a mop
just poke it in there
dying and some asian ladies she's not
gonna steal
every 30 seconds she does the i don't
the i don't have nothing
yeah yeah they gotta do that that move
[ __ ] not over there
with no attitude because like look white
people black people
they do it in this yeah i ain't got
nothing i know it's a technicality like
we all know we have to do that
i don't have nothing here i don't have
this
not only that but more importantly for a
casino uh the asian dealers very rarely
carry on
conversation conversations so more hands
get played
more hands get played more money the
house
and because they just to keep it
[ __ ] you they might as well just get a
robot to do it then
at that point they they have one you
can't [ __ ]
cynthia kim [ __ ] harper connecticut
and her husband who owns the [ __ ] she
works there at night and go [ __ ] runs
the dry cleaners at the daytime
and the nail shop and she comes and she
doesn't give you any personality
how do they ever get [ __ ]
personality people in the world the most
why do they [ __ ] the most that's right
where is all this [ __ ] unfun come
coming from
and non-enjoyable eggs getting together
to have billions of these [ __ ]
nonsensical unfun cheap human beings
i love you
you ruined communicating with patients
foreign
i can't even go to a chinese restaurant
without thinking of patrice and his take
on this whole thing and it's like really
you want to be upset asians
prove me differently i have an asian dry
cleaner
asian laundry person asian fish tank
cleaner the guy
and i've known all of them all of them
the only one that's
that's worse is this black security
guard out here
who doesn't give you a frequent flyer i
come here probably
enough for you to not treat me really
i gotta sign the book too really you're
gonna put the clip
on my [ __ ] patrice o'neill sticker
yeah like you gotta
so the asian dry cleaner there's no
frequent flyer there's no
thing free shirt after [ __ ] okay
if if the bill is a 1.99 he goes i only
charge you a dollar ninety-eight it's
okay
yeah it's okay the penny is [ __ ]